blackface has a long and painful and
racist history in this country so we
want to give you a heads up that some of
the images were about to show you are
very disturbing blackface became popular
in the mid 1800s and minstrel shows when
white performers darken their faces to
depict african-americans in prejudicial
and offensive ways the well-known
blackface minstrel character jump Jim
Crow was the namesake for Jim Crow laws
the measures that enforced segregation
in the south even black actors were
forced to wear black face in part to
make white audiences feel superior civil
rights organizations have pointed out
for decades that blackface dehumanizes
black people and reinforces very harmful
racial stereotypes
Dajuan de lijn Ruiz is curator of music
and performing arts at the National
Museum of African American history and
culture in Washington and joins us at
the table to discuss we had such a
spirited conversation in the makeup room
this morning so I'm so glad you're here
I think why don't you start us off by
letting people know why this is so
offensive because I have so many white
friends and say I don't understand it I
meant no harm
I admire Diana Ross I admire as a
Attorney General said Kurtis Blow and I
was really trying to pay a compliment
well it's really a part of it is really
understanding the history of black face
and the inception which started in the
mid 1800s and what it was was white
performers blacking up their face and
caricature in African Americans looking
at them as lazy unintelligent
stereotyping in their to certain
stereotypes like the mammy figure Uncle
Tom the trickster and so all these
caricatures were taking elements of
African American people and making them
objects for ridicule and humor and
entertainment cut to where we are today
they're not trying to play the mammy
role or the Jim Crow role no they're not
it's a different it's of lingering
images of black face and minstrel see
that really kind of set the course for
popular entertainment which has gone
throughout the 20th and the 21st century
people's intentions matter dwindle in
here not necessarily because I
understand how people would think it is
a form of flattery it's a form of just
imitating somebody you would
but it's knowing the history that really
makes a difference and how painful these
images were for African Americans and
what it's set off in this country of a
way of stereotyping and dehumanizing
people based on the color of their skin
which was an effort to enforce
powerlessness which is if you dehumanize
and make them lesser then you can do any
other thing you want with the laws it is
a question of power and when people ask
the opposite someone had mentioned white
chicks the movie when the Wayans
brothers dress up as white women and it
is different so why so well I think it's
that power dynamic you talk about with
appropriating people's images and it it
is when you have the power to do that
and to a press it's very different than
a cultural exchange of ferrochromium Jim
Crow the original blackface character
became to epitomize the Jim Crow laws
state and local laws that enforced
segregation enforced bigotry enforced
Plessy v Ferguson all of that that's the
history of this country to Gail's
question what about those who are saying
and this was the conversation that Gail
brought up this morning those who are
saying that during in an inspiring way
an aspiring way to dress up as Beyonce
or a cultural figure of prominence it's
still painful it's still painful
african-americans and I think there are
also a lot of white Americans who feel
the same way those images are tied to a
legacy of oppression and slavery and
objectifying and devaluing people so if
you look at the cultural mores of the
time the images really have a lasting
impact and don't mean what people intend
necessarily as with so many things in
this day and age it's hard not to have
children of young age become aware of
news and the headlines as I was
preparing for this last night my
six-year-old was next to me and he asked
what this was all about what's the
teachable moment here how do we talk to
generations of children to come about
why this is so important I think part of
it is knowing the history and explaining
the history to your children in a
that breaks down the stereotype to see
where it came from there's a room for
atonement here Ron Doolin where some
people because some people may be losing
their jobs is there room for atonement I
think so I I don't think this is a way
to label people for a lifetime people
change they become educated they evolve
is it possible that someone who dressed
up in this way 30 years ago is that
person racist that's not for me to say
but I think the act of going through
this means that there's a lack of
understanding about the meaning of this
does that equate to racism you'd have to
talk to that individual personally but
it is an act that perpetuates racist
ideology in that way so hard to talk
about race but we have got to have this
conversation yeah Ron de lijn talk about
it well thank you for having me and we
should know now note that there is more
on the website of the museum too if you
would like to know more as well as visit
the museum right because there's a lot
about the history that we can all learn
absolutely thank you thank you